-Performing his global hit
"Calm Down" and "Holiday"
from his album "Rave & Roses,"
give it up for Rema.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Baby, calm down, calm down ♪
♪ Girl, this your body e
put in my heart for lockdown ♪
♪ For lockdown, oh lockdown ♪
♪ Girl, you sweet like Fanta
ooh, Fanta ooh ♪
♪ If I tell you, say,
"I love you" ♪
♪ No dey form yanga oh,
oh yanga oh ♪
♪ No tell me no, no, no, no,
woah, woah, woah, woah ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Baby, come gimme your ♪
♪ Lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-woah-
woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪ You got me like,
"Woah-woah-woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪ Woah-woah-woah" ♪
♪ Shawty come gimme your
lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo ♪
♪ Woah-woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪ I see this fine girl for my
party she wear yellow ♪
♪ Every other girl they dey do
too much but this girl mellow ♪
♪ Naim I dey find situation
I go use take tell am hello ♪
♪ Finally I find way to talk to
the girl but she no wan follow ♪
♪ Who you come dey form for? ♪
♪ Why you no wan' conform? ♪
♪ Then I start to feel
her brown bum, warm ♪
♪ But she dey gimme small,
small woah ♪
♪ I know say she sabi pass
that one, one ♪
♪ But she feeling insecure
woah ♪
♪ 'Cause her friends go dey gum
her like chewing gum ♪
♪ Go dey gum her like chewing
gum, woah, woah, ooh ♪
♪ Baby, calm down, calm down ♪
♪ Girl, this your body e
put in my heart for lockdown ♪
♪ For lockdown, oh lockdown ♪
♪ Girl, you sweet like Fanta,
sweet like Fanta ♪
♪ If I tell you, say,
"I love you" ♪
♪ No dey form yanga oh,
oh yanga oh ♪
♪ No tell me no, no, no, no,
woah, woah, woah, woah ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Baby, come gimme your ♪
♪ Lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-woah-
woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪ You got me like,
"Woah-woah-woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪ Woah-woah-woah" ♪
♪ Shawty come gimme your
lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo ♪
♪ Woah-woah-woah-woah-woah ♪
♪♪
-♪ I will never forget
the time wey ♪
♪ Bad belle them cast us away ♪
♪ Fast forward to today ♪
-♪ Everyday na holiday-ayy,
ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Everyday say na holiday ♪
♪ Oya day, oya day,
day, day, owey ♪
♪ First you go be the bad guy ♪
♪ Then you go be the actor ♪
♪ Because I wan feed
my family ♪
♪ Na 'em make me thief
my own guy laptop ♪
♪ Came out alive,
omo me I thank ♪
♪ God My money big,
you go need tractor ♪
♪ If e be say you wan
carry my weight ♪
♪ You go need new gym
instructor ♪
♪ Straight out of Benin ♪
♪ I drop "Rema - EP" ♪
♪ 2019, they think say
the gbedu go finish ♪
♪ My music is travelin' ♪
♪ From India to Asia to Berlin ♪
♪ The thing wey been pain me ♪
♪ Be say una no wan be-believe ♪
♪ I will never forget
the time wey ♪
♪ Bad belle them cast us away ♪
♪ Fast forward to today ♪
♪ Everyday na holiday-ayy,
ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Everyday say na holiday ♪
♪ Oya day, oya day, day,
day, owey ♪
-♪ I will never forget
the time wey ♪
♪ Bad belle them cast us away ♪
-♪ Fast forward to today ♪
♪ Everyday na holiday-ayy,
ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Everyday say na holiday ♪
♪ Oya day, oya day, day,
day, owey ♪
♪ I will never forget
the time wey ♪
♪ Bad belle them cast us away ♪
♪ Fast forward to today ♪
♪ Everyday na holiday-ayy,
ayy, ayy ♪
♪ Everyday say na holiday ♪
♪ Oya day, oya day, day,
day, owey ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]